hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear movie review show hope you guys
had a happy thanksgiving couple days ago
if you celebrated it and the movie we're
talking about today this is a movie
that i actually originally saw probably
back in the early to mid 2000s
when i was kind of watching a lot of
japanese horror and i remember really
kind of digging it at the time
um and sort of images from it
really kind of stuck with me after a
while and i was just like i kind of dug
it because like the premise was so weird
and then for a long time like i would
kind of think about it every now and
then like oh you know i should really
like revisit that one of these days
because i remember that being pretty
good but it seemed like for a long time
it was really sort of hard to get hold
of
and then i noticed that a few months ago
i guess it was a few months ago that
amazon prime had added it to their
lineup and actually so if you have a
subscription amazon prime you can watch
it on there for free so i thought to
myself well now is as good a time as any
to you know revisit it and see if i like
it as much as i liked it the first time
and that is the 2000 film uzumaki now
interestingly uh i was kind of doing
like i said i just remembered watching
it back in 2003 2004 whatever it was i'm
sure i probably just rented it because
it didn't get a theatrical release in
the united states except maybe on the
west coast so it was like very very
limited um so it wasn't one but it was
one that i kind of heard about just
because the premise was so strange and
uh and it sounded kind of cool and i
feel like it had some buzz around it at
the time like when it came out but then
i didn't really hear much about it
subsequently and when i was researching
it recently
i wouldn't say that the horror community
is you know it that the overwhelming
number of reviews were negative but they
were very mixed it really did seem like
a lot of people dug it to an extent but
i saw like a couple horror channels
covering it that were just kind of like
this is really really not good like
really not a good well i mean it doesn't
help that uh if you didn't know uzumaki
is an adaptation of the junji ito manga
of the same name i haven't read the
manga although i have seen a lot of the
artwork and stuff like that from it so i
have kind of like you know flipped
through it and i know what the you know
what the gist of the story is so a lot
of people are kind of excited to see
this brought to the screen and so i kind
of feel like mostly that people weren't
necessarily [ __ ] on the movie it's
just they were just saying it was kind
of a disappointing adaptation of the
manga which is fair because like i said
you know books are always better and i
will say too that at the time that this
movie came out in early 2000 the manga
was actually not finished yet so if
you've actually in recent times you know
read the manga and are like oh wow there
was you know there's a movie adaptation
of it keep in mind that the ending and
[ __ ] like that is going to be completely
different um and the explanation for the
curse or whatever it is is not really
well it's not really gone into all that
much but it's not the same as what was
in the manga because the manga wasn't uh
wasn't done yet like when the movie came
out
so this movie was actually directed by a
guy named higuchinsky that's kind of his
uh that's his pseudonym i guess uh his
real name is
akihiro higuchi
and it seemed like prior to him doing
this movie
he hadn't really done a lot uh i think
i'm not sure if he did kind of like more
promotional kind of work like music
videos or that kind of thing uh so he's
like a style kind of guy
which comes through very much in this
movie
um and after that it seemed like he
really didn't do much after that either
like he did another movie that was also
a jinji ito adaptation and then he did
another movie that was kind of like uh
like a battle royale type
type situation so he did one like that
but i think that's about it uh at least
as far as you know as far as i could
determine i don't know i just kind of
feel like i didn't realize the mixed
feelings that people had about this
because like i said when i saw it back
in the early 2000s i thought it was like
pretty cool like visually
and uh so in the subsequent years
you know so i'd think about it like off
and on and i was like oh i got to
re-watch it but i didn't realize like
how
i don't know if i want to say divisive
but i feel like a lot of people
particularly people that were really
into the manga i kind of feel like they
were really disappointed by
this film adaptation of it because they
thought it didn't really live up to
the potential now i will say i'm not
entirely sure how much this costs to
make i've heard that it only
cost like a million dollars
uh for tooth and for 2000 that's pretty
low budget so i will say that a concept
like this i don't know i kind of i don't
i don't want to necessarily say you need
like a bigger budget because you could
probably do it i i feel like maybe live
action isn't the
isn't maybe the medium for this which i
think was a lot of uh people's complaint
they're like well it should have been
animated uh because you could have done
a lot more without because there's a lot
of like really weird [ __ ] in here and
you know the film does a good job
portraying that with the limited budget
that it had but i do kind of feel like
animation might be better now last i
heard and i don't know
this was uh earlier this year or last
year i heard that adult swim
was doing uh an animated adaptation of
this like a series
so
i don't know like it looks cool uh so
we'll see how that goes i don't think
it's it's premiered yet as far as i know
like i said i'm not i'm not real up on
the manga i'm not real up on japanese
horror like you know i i see it here and
there but my knowledge of it is very
spotty uh you know this was just one
that i had heard about back in the day
because i was talking about how weird it
is uh so and i remember digging it and
then i watched it again now i will say
that this time when i watched it
i did i liked it but i didn't like it as
much as the first time i think i guess
because it didn't seem as weird to me
because i knew what to expect
and so i think maybe like the flaws of
it kind of stuck out to me more and
the more reviews i read of it and the
more uh research i did about like the
background of it the more i kind of like
agreed with some of the criticisms of it
as well it's still a good movie if you
like really weird [ __ ] it's kind of like
i know i use this a lot but um you know
it does have like a little bit of an
unsettling like david lynchy kind of
vibe not overtly but it does have a
little bit of that and it's kind of like
and it also it she kind of shades into
like love crafty type of [ __ ] too again
not overtly
but
it's it has like a little bit of a
surrealist vibe to it and it's very kind
of visual now the thing about it and
i've heard that this is the case with
the manga as well
is that and i found this a lot i don't
know how like i said my my knowledge of
asian horror is very spotty so please uh
correct me if i'm wrong
but it does seem like most of the asian
horror that i've read or watched has a
lot more of an episodic quality rather
than you know your typical western
three-act structure type narrative so
it's just kind of like a different way
of storytelling like i found the grudge
like very episodic and you know various
things like that so this kind of goes
like that too now with the manga i think
i don't want to say it's like a series
of short stories or like an anthology
because i don't think it quite is
it's all based around this one town and
they're all thematically similar but
then it kind of just like explores
different people in the town and how
they're affected by
this curse that's overtaking it you know
i kind of feel like when they were first
talking about adapting the movie they
were saying well maybe we should make it
like an anthology which might have been
a better idea because the way this movie
is it comes across
i don't want to say it comes across
almost like an anthology like the
stories are disconnected because there
is some attempt made to narratively link
the stories together and the characters
together
but it still has that episodic quality
to it where we're just like going like
this person gets possessed by the curse
and then this person gets possessed by
the curse or whatever and then it just
kind of like ends and like i said that
might have been just a function of oh
the manga wasn't finished and they
weren't really sure where to go with it
because the thing about the curse at the
center of uzumaki is that
there doesn't really seem to be at least
according to the movie
uh and at least according to the manga
as you know because i did kind of read
the plot synopsis on wikipedia so i
could kind of be more informed about
that but it really does seem like the
curse there's not really any way to stop
it or there's not really any way to
fight it so it's almost kind of like you
know you're kind of [ __ ]
either way you know what i mean so it's
not like you you can have this big
moment at the end where it's like we've
defeated the thing it's like that
doesn't really happen
so you so you kind of have that too so
maybe
maybe from that perspective like the way
that the story goes is kind of like
maybe unsatisfying i'm not really sure
but so anyway uh this movie
i guess in japan it got released uh on a
double bill with uh the movie tomy
replay which again i think that's
because the tomi books that's another
jinji ito uh manga as well so what we
have here the character at the center of
this really or i guess the character
whose eyes were seeing everything
through mostly
is this high school girl named kiria
and she's kind of like and i'm sure i'm
gonna butcher all the names so don't
like don't come at me
you know what i'm saying i'm just saying
that right now
now she lives in this town
called kurutsu
which i think means
black vortex town or something like that
so she lives in this small town
and uh the first thing she notices
that's going like a little bit weird
is that she has this boyfriend slash
childhood friend uh named shuichi saito
and she sees like his dad
kind of squatting down in an alley like
videotaping a snail like climbing up the
wall
so she thinks that she goes over and
like is like hey what's what's up what
are you doing or whatever and the guy
just like doesn't even acknowledge her
existence so she's like ah that's a
little weird uh but then she doesn't
really think that much more about it now
there's also this whole thing like a
kind of a recurring thing of this dude
who has a big crush on her
and keeps every time she's walking home
from school or whatever he'll like jump
out in her face and be like hey like i
like to surprise people and you have to
be my girlfriend and she's just like bro
like leave me alone and like he's very
very
rapey and like getting up at her face
and everything but it's almost kind of
like
portrayed as funny i don't know there
there is kind of like some goofy [ __ ] in
this which
maybe i don't know i kind of feel like
they maybe should have gone a serious
way with it because as weird as this
movie is and as creepy as some of the
imagery is like the mood and atmosphere
of it are kind of creepy but then you
know every now and then they'll just be
like this goofy [ __ ] and i kind of feel
like it would have been scarier because
it's not it's not a scary movie
it has unsettling moments
the visuals are cool but it's not like
scary you know what i'm saying and i
think maybe that's why maybe that's and
i'm not saying that it has like tonal
whiplash or anything it's not that bad
but you do have these kind of like she
you know it's kind of like a creepy
scene where you just find a guy who's
just like
obsessively like filming a snail that's
climbing up the wall and doesn't hear
you when you talk to him
so that's like kind of creepy and you're
like huh that's pretty weird and
unsettling but then all of a sudden you
have this dude like jumping in your face
coming hey i like surprise people
doesn't you know what i mean and it's
just like goofy and then there's like
there's one time
and i don't think this is repeated now
that i'm thinking about i don't know why
i just thought of this but there's one
part where there's like a transition and
like the transition is this kind of
crazy like and it has like this
like kind of cartoon noise and it's like
i don't think that's done again and i
was like okay that was a choice but uh
yeah so i mean like i said a lot of the
stuff in this
and actually watching it again there is
a lot of stuff kind of going on in the
background of this and the way that it's
filmed that does kind of inform the
theme of the movie like sometimes like
the camera will like turn in a spiral or
sometimes there's like digital spirals
like in the background you know like in
the clouds or like in the wall or
something like that and like you don't
necessarily notice them the first time
you watch the movie but then you kind of
spot all of this spiral action going on
in the background so that's like kind of
cool but i didn't really get like some
of the shots in there i i didn't really
get why they were in there i mean maybe
i'm just like missing out or maybe i'm
dumb or whatever but it's like some of
the stuff like i said that kind of
cartoony sound effect i was just kind of
like all right i don't know why they did
that but okay so she ends up uh talking
to
her boyfriend she's like yeah what's the
deal with your dad because i'm pretty
sure i'm paraphrasing
what's the deal with your dad because i
saw i'm pretty sure it was him and he
was like
you know filming a snail in an alley
what's that about so uh so then he says
yeah
this uh he's like my dad is losing his
[ __ ] mind pretty much uh he's like he
has become obsessed with vortexes and
spirals and he basically doesn't even go
to work anymore and he just like walks
around all day and collects things that
have a spiral pattern on them and he
just like puts him in the house like his
collection now and he's just like
wigging out we can't even get through to
him anymore so we don't even know what
the [ __ ] deal with that is and like
so kitty is kind of like yeah that's
kind of funny he's like dude it's not
funny you know what i mean uh so yeah so
his whole story and it's interesting too
because even when i'm
when i looked at the wikipedia like
breakdown of the plot of this
they even broke it down into like
episodes even though that's not
necessarily like the order that the film
goes in you know what i mean so it's
kind of like we're like oh we're
following uh shuichi's dad who
becomes obsessed with spirals and like i
said one of my favorite shots in this
actually and they might have used like
this partial kind of thing for the cover
but where he's kind of just squatting in
the middle of this room that he's
made for his spiral collection and
there's just all this spiral [ __ ] like
all over and it looks really cool oh
another thing too is that visually this
movie is green you guys it's like super
green you know what i mean you know how
the matrix came out and it had that
green tint to it like you know um and
then how every movie after that kind of
did the same thing you know what i mean
to like make it creepy uh this movie
does this is a very very green movie i
had forgotten how green it was and i
don't have a problem with uh with green
movies i'm just saying
i'm not and i'm not actually even sure
if the version that amazon prime got
because some of the visuals in this are
so cool and i just kind of feel like it
looks sort of muddy you know what i mean
so i don't know if that was just the
transfer or
you know i don't know it just looks kind
of muddy and there's like a really
strange
kind of look to it so so some of the
visuals don't look as awesome as maybe
they should have looked because
everything just has this weird green
dull
sort of filter over it like everything
almost looks monochromatic you know what
i'm saying it's not like a real colorful
movie it's just like a very dour like
green film uh so there's that as well
so uh so the dad he gets obsessed with
spirals until it gets to a point where
he decides
uh he actually has uh kiria's dad who's
a potter like an award-winning potter uh
make him like a dish with a spiral in
the bottom and all this other stuff so
that's kind of a whole other thing but
he decides eventually that he's so
obsessed with the spiral shape that he's
going to
get a mirror and like film himself with
his because he's making like a video
diary of like all the spirals that he
finds
and he's gets a mirror and he's going to
film himself getting in the washing
machine or the dryer and basically
spinning himself to death so
actually i thought this was kind of
effective because how they build it up
because you know what he did like as
soon as
there's a thing where uh where uh shoot
where what's her face kyrie goes to the
um
house to like drop the dish off like
from her dad
and they don't show it but it's like
they just show it from the outside and
then you just hear her scream
and then shuichi and his mom come home
and they're like what the [ __ ] and she's
like pointing over at the washing
machine or the dryer or whatever and
they look in there but they don't show
it to you right then they don't actually
show you it until later so they kind of
like tease
like what
what the dude looked like like all
spiraled up inside the and actually if
you look at the drawing like from the
manga it actually looks really cool but
it just like turned him into a spiral so
there's that
so
as it goes on so he gets cremated
and then his like every time somebody
gets cremated which i think like i said
was another chapter in the manga every
time somebody gets cremated like the
smoke like spirals out of the
crematorium thing chimney and then kind
of like makes this big spiral in the sky
now his ashes particularly they go down
to this place called dragonfly pond and
then i guess that kyrie's dad like goes
to the pond to get clay like for his
pots and he somehow gets infected with
it but i don't think that like i said
there's not a real clear thing about how
the spirals like infect everybody you
know what i'm saying because it doesn't
seem like oh you have to touch the
person or you have to interact with the
person it just seems like
random people get started get obsessed
with spirals like for whatever things
and so then it just starts to affect
them in a particular way so like at the
school
where uh kittia goes to there's this kid
who
they say that he's like you know doing
gymnastics or whatever like up on this
spiral staircase and he falls down the
middle and splats in the in the center
which is actually like a really
effective scene but then some of the
students like there's this one kind of
chubby kid
who
comes to school
they say well he only comes to school
when it rains and he takes like a really
long time to get there like he's always
late and he shows up and he's like
covered with slime
and then he has like all this like this
lumpy [ __ ] like coming out of his back
and then it turns out that some of those
high school students and some of like
other people in town are basically like
turning into big human snails so they
kind of have that too like they kind of
show like later on there's like a news
report where they're like human snails
in this town or whatever and then
there's like these human-sized snails
like climbing up the side of the
building and stuff so i liked that
imagery as well uh so shuichi's mom
she also like she freaks out when she
sees like the whole spiraling thing from
the crematorium and i guess she gets
infected too
they put her in the hospital and then
she starts freaking out like every time
she sees spirals so she does like gross
[ __ ] like she cuts off her uh
fingerprints and like cuts off all her
hair because her hair is curly and
there's all this other kind of [ __ ] and
they're um you know like her son is
basically like oh [ __ ] like what if she
finds out that there's like the a spiral
thing like inside your ear and all this
other which spoiler alert she does
actually find out at some point or she
like it occurs to her so there's that
kind of thing and then there's this girl
at school this is like one of the weird
like i said this is one of the weird
kind of comedic things that i'm not sure
entirely works
but the school that katie goes to
there's actually this little click of
you know three little little mean girls
they're not main characters or anything
i don't even know what their names are
but
the head one
is just this crazy like over exaggerated
like she has these wispy bangs and she
has these glasses with a chain on them
and she's always like smoking and she's
like very very like all of her gestures
are very exaggerated and she's always
kind of like talking about how she wants
to be the center of attention and you
know if you're not uh if no one's paying
attention to you you're not alive and
all this other stuff and i guess they're
supposed to they're setting up that
she's kind of like the popular girl and
she has like all of these
followers you know what i mean but when
the spiral infects her
it doesn't kill her because a lot of the
spirals when they infect people people
generally end up committing suicide in
various like horrible ways but it
doesn't do that to her it kind of like
just makes her hair like super super
spirally like it gets more and more
spirally like as the time goes on and
then it's like this big crazy thing and
then it seems like all the girls in
school are like now following her like
she's like the spiral queen or whatever
so i don't think anything bad happens to
her
but stuff like there's like this
reporter that comes into town um who's
kind of heard about this weird [ __ ]
going on so he's there's a little bit of
like him helping kiriet and uh shuichi
like with their investigation
and then there's a scene where the the
creepy stalker kid who's always like
jumping out in kyrgyz face um he decides
well i'm gonna make you remember me
forever or whatever and he jumps in
front of the reporter's car
and ends up like getting his body
twisted around the front axle which is
actually like a pretty cool looking i
mean it's pretty gross and it's like
pretty cool looking but then like the
reporter like smashes his head in the
windshield and that makes a spiral and
all this other stuff so it's kind of
like like i said it's very episodic it
sort of
makes an attempt like when the before
the reporter gets killed they do this
kind of sort of and to me it felt a
little half-assed but maybe i don't know
maybe um i just didn't like
get it or whatever but they kind of
almost wanted to make it seem like oh
dragonfly pond maybe was the center of
like there used to be like a serpent
worshiping cult like a long time ago and
maybe that's what's causing this
outbreak but like i said it's very
half-assed and not really explored to
any great degree there's not really any
explanation for it um it's just
basically like well all of a sudden ever
like people in this town started getting
obsessed by spirals and started
either transforming into snails for
example or uh just decided they were
gonna kill themselves in ways that made
their bodies spiral
and so you don't really have like an
outside perspective like there's a
newscaster that comes into the town and
like does like about the human snail
thing
and uh you know she's basically like
doing that but they don't really say
you know why this town um is it
spreading outside of the town they do
kind of seem to they kind of seem to
suggest that because they're like oh the
the snails are all leaving the town
i mean i kind of get
i think and i think i picked up on this
more the second time i watched it
because the first time i watched it i'm
like wow this is just weird as [ __ ]
whatever it doesn't make any sense like
i said it's not a narrative like i said
it's very episodic that it is kind of
linked together like the characters and
stuff but it's not like some big
overarching narrative it's mostly just
like and then here's this person and the
weird way that spiral got them you know
what i mean um but it's so it's not that
but
i kind of got though
that
i'm i'm guessing that the spiral vortex
type of uh imagery
they're kind of like um it's almost kind
of like a metaphor for this little town
and like nothing ever changes and no one
ever leaves and it's that kind of thing
i don't think that was
conveyed as well as maybe it could been
because that because that's actually
like a really good
you know but there were some visual
cues in the movie that kind of suggested
that so which i didn't pick up on the
first time
so there is more going on in this movie
and i kind of feel like this is maybe
one that you need to see a few times
but i will say that it does have some
weaknesses like i said i could have done
without
you know sort of the more comedic
elements to it because i think that took
away from the weirdness uh you know and
the unsettlingness like i said it's not
scary
but
some of the images are cool and like
unsettling the special effects are not
great uh it was 2000 this is a pretty
low budget movie um so some of the
special effects don't super hold up but
the images are so surreal that it almost
kind of like gets away with it because
it almost it's not like cartoonish but
you know it's obviously it's not
portraying anything real so it can kind
of like get away with it to a certain
degree um like i said that i kind of
feel like it maybe would have looked
better if it didn't look so
muddy i didn't mind the green cast i
thought that was kind of cool and made
it sort of like look otherworldly and
creepy and stuff but i i kind of feel
like there could have been more
delineation i guess the shots are
actually composed quite well
and the visuals look good and stuff but
you know it's just the the black seemed
a little muddy to me and i'm not really
sure like i said if that was just the
the copy that i watched that's on amazon
prime maybe it was my computer who knows
i don't really know what it was or if
that's actually what the movie looks
like
um some of the acting was a little
iffy
um the main girl is fine uh the guy the
guy that plays the boyfriend shuichi
uh i think this was his first movie
and i don't know if he's been anything
since then he just comes across there's
nothing wrong with his character exactly
but he just comes across as very
unemotional like it's almost kind of
like i guess in the manga he was a more
animated type character you know more
emotional
uh in this he just comes across like
he's either in like shocked or he
doesn't like give a [ __ ] about anything
like he just comes across like that like
he's like yeah my my dad's going crazy
from spirals it's pretty upsetting you
know what i mean it's just he's very
very deadpan and it's so like i said it
seemed like an odd choice uh and the kid
that plays the like i said the kid that
plays the stalker kid that keeps jumping
out in that girl's face it's he was kind
of like irritating because he he just
seemed like hey i'm comic relief guy and
you know when he gets hit by the car i'm
like good you know you know what i mean
it was that kind of thing because he
just kept like jumping and she's just
like look dude i don't i have a
boyfriend and i don't like you and he
just kept like jumping out at her and
i'm just like really she's like just
sock him in the nuts but i guess she
never did but at least he got hit by a
car so there's that the characters like
the actors that played like the older
characters like the moms and the dads
and stuff they were all really good like
i said the acting wasn't terrible it's
just some of it was sort of
bland or you know not
i just kind of feel like particularly uh
the shuichi character
considering the horror of what was
happening around them it seemed like he
wasn't reacting with the appropriate
amount of
you know
holy shitness um it just seemed like he
was very i don't know but you know what
i mean just maybe that's like i said
that was just the choice that he made
and you know i'm not going to get too
much into it and again because this
movie
was
uh made before the manga was finished it
kind of just sort of ends a little bit
abruptly in the sense that you know
shuichi gets taken over by the spiral
and
you know he just start his body starts
contorting which is actually quite cool
looking uh you know his legs start
twisting together and he's trying to
like crawl toward uh kittied and be like
you have to get out of the town you have
to go to the town uh they never leave
it's like they talk about leaving but
like i said i think
that that was sort of like tied in with
the theme because it's like well we
talked about leaving the town but you
but we never leave so it's kind of like
you can't leave sort of situation i
think maybe is the the implication there
but yeah so his whole body starts
twisting and he's just like you have to
get out of town you have to go to town
before it takes you too and then but his
just he's basically just like taken over
by it uh and then that's pretty much it
like he just like spirals up and then
like kind of jumps at her and she
screams and then it just cuts to black
you know they i think like in the end
credits they have some stuff about
things that happen with other towns folk
because like i said the the manga is
also almost kind of like like i said
it's almost almost kind of like a short
story collection but all the stories are
sort of linked so the movie is kind of
like that too it is totally worth
watching if you're into japanese horror
and you haven't seen it um just for the
like weird ass imagery but
i've kind of like i said i haven't read
the manga but i do kind of feel like the
overwhelming opinion of people that are
really into the manga because i think
that's jinji ito is probably best
regarded one as of all the ones that
he's written that seems to be a favorite
so um pretty much everybody i
read and know about that read the manga
like thought the movie was pretty
disappointing you know take of that
which you will if you haven't read the
manga you'll probably enjoy it just fine
but like i said if you're a big fan of
the manga then probably
then it might just like bum you out
because it's like oh it could have been
so much better but like i said it was
2000 it was low budget
you know the director wasn't super
experienced and honestly it's an
enjoyable movie he has some parts that
are kind of boring and kind of drag and
stuff and didn't need to be in there but
overall i think it was like a cool ass
move and like i said especially if you
like
really weird [ __ ] it's like the tinges
on lovecraftian just like like i said
don't expect it to be scary or anything
like that but it did have some kind of
like disquieting
uh sort of atmosphere sort of mood to it
and some of the visuals are actually
like really cool but don't expect it to
be like super scary or anything like
that because it's not but yeah so if you
uh would like cedar or if you've seen it
or if you've read the manga and you have
an opinion about it then please share it
in the comments as i said it's streaming
on amazon prime if you have a
subscription you can watch it right now
and share your opinion about it and that
will do it for this flickers of fear i
will see you guys on the next one
bye